What's up guys my name is Colin McNeil, for theScore esports.
Last week ex-Halo player and current Fortnite streamer Ninja made mainstream
headlines when he queued with Drake, Travis Scott and Juju Smith-Schuster, breaking a
lot of Twitch records in the process.
Now I know, you and I could probably not care less about the latest celebrity gossip.
But you gotta admit, when someone who's mainstream famous, or just famous in a
community that isn't gaming, streams. It's kinda hype.
With that in mind we thought this would be the
perfect opportunity to bring you The Top 10 Celebrities
who have streamed on Twitch.
Well guys, we decided to start our list off
on a high note for this one, with the D-O-Double
G himself Snoop Dogg streaming battle royale title SOS in January of 2018.
(Stream)
Now let me blunt here, it appears that Snoop Dogg wasn't actually playing the game so much as he was
watching, reacting and controlling the mic.
We just hope that doesn't cause his future streaming career to go up in smoke.
(Stream)
Next up on our list, Felicia Day is widely known as one of the queens of the nerds.
She’s most famous for her role as the producer of The Guild, a series that is based off of
her life as a gamer.
Felicia was also a member of the cast of Buffy: The Vampire Slayer and Supernatural among
others.
In recent years Felicia has built her stream on Twitch playing a variety of games
(Stream)
Including: Rise of the Tomb Raider and Dragon Age: Inquisition.
Number eight on our list might be the only member of this Top 10 that’s actually competed at
an esports event.
Hayward has always been an advocate for esports
and even competed in the IGN Pro League during
the NBA lockout in 2011.
Alright Gordon let's get you into shape! Now what league are you in?
The NBA!
I meant in StarCraft II
Oh, Gold.
When he hits the the rift, Hayward can be found in the top lane playing champions like
Tryndamere and outplaying his lane opponents like we see here:
(Stream)
R&B and hip-hop performer T-Pain was one of the first celebrities to make their mark on
Overwatch after the game came out.
The “Buy you a Drank” singer’s on-stream
antics are just as hilarious as you’d expect.
(Stream)
He can be found playing a variety of heros,
from Junkrat to Lucio to Hanzo.
(Stream)
Famous DJ, producer and musician Deadmau5, comes in at number six and he's likely the celebrity who’s taken
the biggest dive into Twitch.
Deadmau5 streams almost everyday with a lot of it lately being PUBG.
(Stream)
He’s also found a unique way to combine
his career with his Twitch personality
by streaming himself working on and creating music.
Of all of the members on this list Deadmau5 is definitely the one most entrenched in Twitch
and streaming culture.
(Stream)
Coming in at number five
Quinton “Rampage” Jackson is a former
UFC Light Heavyweight champion and has recently
been streaming PlayerUnknown’s Battlegrounds.
(Stream)
Jackson has even been known to get some winner winner chicken dinners, proving that he can
go on a rampage in and out of the ring.
(Stream)
Lupe Fiasco is the second hip-hop star to
touch down on our list.
The “Superstar” rapper has been a huge
supporter of the Fighting Game Community for
years now and is more than just a Street Fighter fan, he’s a player.
(Stream)
He even allowed Capcom to use a song from his newest album for Colleen’s announcement
trailer.
(Trailer)
His biggest gaming moment was certainly his showmatch against Daigo at the Street Fighter V
release party.
(Stream)
Taking the third spot on this list is
Rick Fox, a true OG of the celebrity dive
into esports and an ex NBA player
with the Boston Celtics and Los Angeles Lakers.
He’s really done it all in esports from
streaming
(Stream)
to becoming part-owner of Echo Fox.
Rick Fox is known for that winning smile and has really entrenched himself in the scene over
the last few years.
Back in February, Fox streamed
for the first time with his son Kyle.
(Stream)
Taking the coveted number two spot on this list
Mia Khalfia has quickly become one of the
most notable online personalities out there.
The former adult actress turned Washington
sports personality and COMPLEX talk show host
has recently started doing IRL streams.
(Stream)
She’s streamed herself doing everything from cooking to
hanging out on the couch playing NBA 2K.
(Stream)
Well I bet you didn’t see this one coming.
Our number one is last week’s record-setting
stream featuring Ninja, and rappers Drake,
Travis Scott and Pittsburgh Steelers wide
receiver JuJu Smith-Schuster.
After initially stumbling to get their comms going the stream quickly smashed Twitch viewership
records and got as high as 630,000 concurrent,
smashing Dr. DisRespects previous record of
388,000.
(Stream)
In what was arguably one of the most iconic moments
in Twitch’s history, the 6 god blessed viewers
all over the world with some memorable stream
highlights.
(Stream)
I’d like to dub this particular stream “Views
from Titled Towers”
(Stream)
Well guys that’s our list. But if your favourite celebrity stream did not make our Top 10
Just flame us in the comments or something okay?
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.